[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine dino torte hat sich
nämlich einen dino zu ihrem geburtstag
gewünscht sie wurde drei und am sonntag
wird bei uns gefeiert
deswegen dachte ich kommt man auf eine
motiv torte das ist ein bisschen typisch
mädchen aber so ist er halt und hat
gesagt sie möchte einen dino einen
saurier und es darf werden davon also
gibt's hier diesem kino der sieg im
ersten schritt vielleicht ein bisschen
kompliziert aus aber diese torte macht
ihr mit einer ganz einfachen schablonen
technik also ich hab dafür einfach ein
bild aus gedruckt so groß wie es ging
bei uns im drucker und das könnt ihr
dann auch machen und jedes motiv
auswählen und wenn ihr die torte nach
machen wollt dann ist es am besten wenn
ihr am tag vorher schon einen
blechkuchen backt damit der kuchen
einfach schön abkühlt und auch nicht
krümelig wird und am besten dann auch
schon die ghana vorbereiten und bei
zimmertemperatur lagern
ich habe jetzt hier bereits eine
schablone ausgedruckt und so geht es
auch wirklich am einfachsten und die
könnt ihr dann auf diese größe
ausdrucken in der er auch die torte
machen möchte
ich habe hier bereits kuchen böden
vorbereitet und zwar könnt ihr da bei
der edel tochter mal nachschauen das
sind nur abbilden und da könnt ihr auch
gerne eurem lieblings kuchen nehmen
wichtig ist nur dass er einfach ein
bisschen fester ist und stabiler ist
damit ja auch gut schneiden kann jetzt
lege ich hier die schablone auf und kann
schon mal grob drumherum schneiden
die zacken oder die stacheln über den
und ich schneide ich jetzt weg damit ich
einfach die rücken form noch schön
bekomme aber ich hab's ja auf die
brauche ich dann nämlich auch noch mal
als schablone
jetzt streiche ich hier ein bisschen
marmelade drauf und dann nehme ich die
kuchen reste und schichten übereinander
und möchtet dann eben so ungefähr die
front um die nur hinbekommen dass die
schnauze ein bisschen dicker den bauch
ein bisschen dicker die arme werden dann
geformt und das mache ich dann einfach
mit etwas kann ich habe jetzt hier eine
vollmilch geht schon vorbereitet das ist
eine creme aus schokolade und sahne und
da könnt ihr einfach mal in meinem basic
video nachschauen wie ich die hersteller
nämlich superschnell und super einfach
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt hier die garage immer
dazwischen
und so kann ich jetzt die kuchen reste
nehmen und übereinander schichten
[Musik]
und jetzt schneide ich den kuchen schön
zurecht sodass der dino auch schöne
rundungen bekommt und die reste die
könnt ihr alle aufheben und zum beispiel
gemeinsam mit der restlichen ghanas cake
pops machen
[Musik]
jetzt wird die komplette torte mit gage
eingestrichen
da mache ich jetzt zuerst eine erste
schicht damit die kübel gebunden werden
dann kommt die torte in den kühlschrank
und kann danach dann noch mal glatt
gestrichen werden
[Musik]
und ich habe ich jetzt hier dino chance
nochmal ausgeschnitten und hier drauf
gelegt damit der partie hier noch einmal
erhöht werden kann
da können da wirklich auch die schablone
zerschneiden so kann man sie nämlich
wirklich gut als hilfe nehmen
nach der kühlen zeit lässt sich der däne
jetzt noch perfekter aus formen und hier
müsst jetzt einfach nur was beachten und
zwar nehme ich jetzt immer wieder die
schablone und schaue jetzt was oben
liegt hier zum beispiel das bein und
deswegen muss ich jetzt hier das bein so
ein bisschen aus formen
die rundungen könnt ihr mit einer
palette gerd streichen aber richtig
glatt wird erst dann wenn er was
flexibles habt und habe ich mir mal aus
einem eimer einfach so die seite raus
geschnitten und damit kommt man richtig
gut und die rundungen und bekommt
wirklich die torte schön glatt und
einmal habe ich das gros und dann noch
zerschnitten in kleinerer form und so
komme ich wirklich an jede ecke und dann
jede rundung dran
[Musik]
und zwischendurch könig jetzt die torte
noch ein bis zwei mal so dass er
wirklich perfekt glatt ist jetzt ist der
dino glatt und ich kann den arm noch
dran machen für den arm lege ich mir
wieder die schablone auf und dann hab
ich kuchen rest damit gallasch verknetet
und klebe so den arm noch auch bei den
augen lege ich die schablone auf und
hören die augenhöhlen so ein bisschen
aus
[Musik]
die nur ist jetzt soweit eigentlich
fertig vorne fehlt nur noch die schnauze
also die zwei nasenlöcher die werden
jetzt auch noch ein gedrückt und dann
kann ich bereits den fondant den ich
dafür verwende weiß kneten da nehme ich
jetzt einfach grünen fondant den
vermutlich mit bisschen geld damit ein
bisschen heller wird
ich lasse ihn von da jetzt so ein
bisschen marmoriert also gelb und grün
damit einfach die haut von dem die noch
nicht ganz gleichmäßig wird
so bekommen wir bisschen struktur rein
und jetzt wird er von dort ausgerollt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die von dort decke auf
den ausbau starb auf rollen dann die
torte nehmen und die besprüht jetzt will
ich ein bisschen wack transport damit
davon braucht haftet und keine blasen
wirft
und ich hatte die torte jetzt auch schon
umgesetzt auch mitfahrten platte ganz
vorsichtig und jetzt über sich erst
einmal den körper und dann noch mal
getrennt davon den kopf es müsste
einfach mit ihren fingern so ein
bisschen tasten und hier diese länder
glattstreichen so dass man eben auch die
struktur und die beine erkennt und die
reste schneide ich dann einfach mit
einem marzipan messer weg
[Musik]
für den bauch habe ich denn von dort ein
bisschen heller gemacht also mit weiß
gemischt und die feinheiten einfach noch
mit modell erzeugt ein bisschen
ausgearbeitet jetzt schneide ich hier
den linken teil gerade zurecht
da nehme ich etwas s-bahn kleber und
streicht jetzt hier auf den bauch
denn hier am schwanz weiterführen
und dann setzt sich den hellen teil
jetzt hier an und drücke ihn vorsichtig
fest
und hier unten zum beispiel das ist so
eine ganz schwer erreichbare stelle da
blicke ich einfach ein bisschen was rein
und zum strukturierten nehme ich einfach
diese lochte in verschiedenen größen und
kann die hier eindrücken
[Musik]
bei der nase form ich jetzt eine kleine
wurst aus bonndorf und klebt sie an das
nasenloch dran und das nasenloch fühle
ich dann aus mit schwarzer zucker
schrift zu bekommen so ein bisschen
tiefe
die krallen mache ich jetzt aus dem
hellen von dort und streichen ein
bisschen zucker kleber auf und formen
sie dann direkt auf dem 10
für die mundpartie vertrete ich jetzt
ein bisschen rot und schwarz und dann
kann man dass da auch direkt rein legen
also ich phorms in der hand so ein
bisschen länglich und flach und dann
einfach schön rein kleben
und ausrottung von dorf vor mich jetzt
noch die zunge davor mich jetzt eine
kugel dann drücke ich sie ein bisschen
platz und in die mitte kommt jetzt hier
noch entspannt jetzt benutze ich ein
bisschen pulver farbe in dunkelbraun und
schwarz um noch die falten nachzuziehen
so bekommen sie ein bisschen mehr tiefe
und bevor jetzt noch die augen
drankommen die möchte ich ganz zum
schluss machen damit das weiße auch
schön weiß bleibt kommt jetzt hier außen
am rücken noch die deko hin
dafür nehme ich jetzt zum einen metallic
farbe die kann ich nämlich drauf pinseln
und dann verdiene ich ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe mit wasser und kann
die schuppen ein bisschen anmalen
[Musik]
und die augen mal ich jetzt mit metallic
farbe auch jetzt noch der untergrund an
der reihe da habe ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen puderzucker eiweißpulver und
wasser verrührt und kann jetzt in
untergrund spachteln ich habe ich noch
schwarze lebensmittelfarbe dazu damit
das ganze ein bisschen grau wird und so
bekommt man den untergrund wirklich
ziemlich schnell und einfach schön
dekoriert
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die fertige dino torte
aus ich finde sie richtig süß und vor
allem geht es wie gesagt super einfach
ihr müsst eben nur beachten dass ihr die
schablone nimmt und dann diese vielen
feinheiten diese details ausarbeiten das
geht echt super falls ihr die dort heute
nach macht dann postet sie doch gerne
und verlinkt mich auf euren bildern dann
kann ich sie nämlich auch anschauen und
falls ihr motiv kartenwünsche habt dann
können wir sie mir gerne schreiben dann
mache ich die natürlich auch gerne für
euch also wir sehen uns wieder beim
nächsten mal
anscheinend kann ich jetzt nicht denn
dieser für das geburtstag also bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]